كان طفلا فقيرا،
لا يملك سوى حذاء ممزقا
فأصبح من أشهر أبطال الفنون القتالية ،
وأحد مؤسسي فن الدفاع عن النفس،
كان يقضي على خصومه في أجزاء من الثانية،
وكان أكبر عدو للمافيا حول العالم،
وعندما تداول الناس بطولاته،
تهافت عليه مخرجي هوليود،
وصار لا يضاهى في القتال والتمثيل،
فكيف وصل بروس لي للعالمية بعمره الصغير؟،،
وفي حين كان لا يزال شابا صغيرا فقد دخل النجومية
من أوسع أبوابها، وصار نجما عالميا يشار له بالأصابع،
عن بروس لي نتحدث وللقصة بقية
عندما ولد بروس لي عام ١٩٤٠،
كان أبوه رجلا فقيرا يقاتل شبح الفقر،
وعاش لي حياة بائسة في طفولته،
حيث كان يجمع دخله اليسير من بيعه للحطب
ليشتري حذاءا وبزة رياضية،
لكي يدخل مدرسة الفنون القتالية التي كان يراقبها خلسة،
ثم يذهب لتطبيق مارآه في الغابة بسرية تامة،
ولما رآه أحد المعلمين وهو يتدرب في الغابة،
أعجب به وضمه لتلاميذه،
وتدرب بروسلي على جميع الفنون القتالية لدى هذا المعلم،
فمرت الأيام وبروس لي يمضي ليؤسس مدرسته الخاصة
في الفنون القتالية خطوة وراء أخرى،
وخلال تأسيسه لمدرسته الخاصة في فنون الدفاع عن النفس
تزوج لي بصديقة له تعرف عليها أثناء دارسته
وتدعى ليندا إيمري، وأنجبت ولدا وفتاة،
يقول لي الملقب بالتنين الصغير
“يظن الناس إنّ الماء رمزٌ للضعف، لكن، إن وضعت الماء
في إناء، فإنّه سيأخذ شكل الإناء، ولو وضعته في زجاجة،
فسيتخذ شكلها، إنّه بلا شكل، ولا يمكن تحطيمه،
لذلك، عليك أن تتكيف، أن تكون منسابًا كما الماء”.
وبفلسفته البسيطة هذه بنا لي نظام قتالي متكامل للدفاع عن النفس..
وصول بروس لي لهذه المكانة لم تكن بهذه البساطة،
فقد كان يحلم بالسفر إلى أمريكا وأن تكون له مدرسته الخاصة في فنون القتال،
وخلال ذلك الوقت لم يدخر لي جهدا إلا وبذله من أجل تحقيق حلمه،
وعندما وصل أمريكا كان الناس والصبية الذين في مثل عمره
خصوصا يتنمرون منه، لأنه صيني ولأنه قصير،
وكانت ملابسه رثة وحالته يرثى لها، وبعد سنوات قليلة
علّم لي الأمريكان درسا قاسيا، وانتقم ممن كانوا يسخرون منه
لكنه وبمواقفه الشجاعة ذاع صيته فاستقطبه أحد مخرجي هوليود،
وهنا انتقل لي نقلة نوعية في الشهرة
وحقق أرقاما مهولة في دخله الشهري بل اليومي،
عندما بدأ لي بطولاته في هوليود، شارك  في المسلسل التليفزيوني
“The Green Hornet”، وبه أصبح أكثر شهرة
وحقق انطلاقة غير معهودة في التمثيل ثم صار بطلا لأفلام الرئيس الكبير
و الاتصال الصيني أو "قبضة الغضب" وطريق التنين
ولعبة الموت الذي كان آخر أفلامه،،
فيما كان بروس لي يخرج ليلا ليقضي على العصابات واللصوص
كما يحدث في أفلام ومسلسلات الخيال،
ويقوم ببطولات خارقة لمساعدة من يتعرض للظلم أو السرقة،
حتى جاء اليوم الذي اصدم فيه لي مع عصابات المافيا،
وهنا بدأت معارك الكر والفر بينهم، وكان لي يصطاد أفراد عصابات
وتجار المخدرات، فاتخذوا منه هدفا لهم، وحاربوه
وحاولوا قتله عشرات المرات لكن الذي يقف أمامهم
هو أحد أقوى أبطال الدفاع عن النفس،
وإلى هنا نكون قد انتهينا من الجزء الأول من قصة البطل بروسلي،
وإذا أردتم معرفة ماتبقى من قصة البطل لي وكيف تم قتله
وكيف كانت نهايته. تابعونا على قناة شاهد لتعرف،
ولا تنسوا الإعجاب بالفيديو والاشتراك بالقناة وتفعيل الجرس ليصلكم جديدنا،